And you look back now with what you know now and all the athletes you've worked
with at the UFC pie,
do you think you would've done anything different in terms of [inaudible]?
Even think about it.
I knew it was fake about it.
All right.
Yeah.
Sorry,
sorry.
Dot.
Oh,
just bought eight rounds.
Why would just sparring rounds,
there's no eight route for,
oh,
you literally just get it.
The slower forced,
the already slow.
I don't know.
It's again,
being a pioneer like you were,
there wasn't really a whole lot of guys before you that we're operating.
I had the other pioneers like the Randy's and the chunks and that's what they
were doing.
So,
oh,
better be tough of it or do what they do.
That's the craziest thing about Ellie Mae is I'm not going to question them.
Boxing it already figured out.
You shouldn't beat the fuck out of each other every day.
They had already kind of figured that out.
The other thing they figured out is,
uh,
we would work with people.
I can spar with Vandelay chuck,
uh,
Randy in boxing,
they don't spar with people.
They're equals past a certain point in camp.
Well,
think about it.
You know a lot about,
they start like is Floyd Mayweather sparring with,
I don't know,
really good people his level.
No,
no,
definitely not.
He's,
he's funny.
People would boxers and he's tooling them.
Yes,
yes.
Yeah.
Have you heard of them though?
They're not famous and rich,
so they're not the best in the world.
They're not elite.
Whereas you think about like a gym,
like our gym.
Like I'll just use Randy's cause I don't want to talk bad about anybody.
Like you're fighting other champions every day.
Right.
Maybe.
Maybe dangerous as fuck.
Yeah.
Maybe drilled together.
Sure.
Learn from each other or role wrestle,
like control your training.
[inaudible] especially guys that are in the same way.
Classes you that may someday fight you.
It's awkward.
Yeah.
And there was no guidebook.
You,
you know,
guys like Keith Jardeen and Rashad Evans figured out,
they're like,
all right,
we already had to fight each other.
We'll try together.
Now we won't have to do it again.
Right.
That's good.
Move.
If it works out.
Um,
the,
the level of guys now is,
it's so extraordinary to see,
like when you see the elite champions of today,
you just have this insane level of,
of,
of fighter.
It's really as a person who's been involved in the sport,
as long as I have,
I still never cease to be amazed at the level of talent of these guys coming up
because some of these guys coming up,
they just could do everything and they can do everything.
It's such a high level and you realizing you're,
you're seeing the results of kids that started out learning MMA when they,
in five,
six years old,
man,
you know,
I had a purse,
I have a personal gym and I remember Rhonda Rousey.
They're like,
man,
she's going to change my bottom line.
All of a sudden I got a mat full of,
uh,
young women just trading one to be a jab at it.
I was like,
this is crazy.
Thank you,
Rodney.
Yeah,
chief for short changed it.
Gina Carano changed a little bit before her,
you know,
people have this idea like,
oh,
you could be pretty and fuck people up.
Like,
oh,
that's a totally different kind of girl.
That's like a superhero,
like a real life superhero.
Now she plays and movies,
right?
Yeah.